the only thing they can be sure of about
the future is it will be absolutely
fantastic Dave Rubin welcome to the in
to the impossible podcast production of
the arthur c clarke Center for human
imagination Ryan it's good to be with
you looking forward to Chet yeah I've
been a fan of yours for for many years
now followed you for a long time and I
want to get into all that and of course
your fantastic new book which I had a
chance to devour this weekend and that's
pretty high praise given all the other
stuff going on in life so first I wanna
start off with with a you know just a
quick question for you and and and that
is you grew up in Long Island as did I
oh all right where you know what I'm
from Stony Brook so I grew up in Stony
Brook the real Island dock in Suffolk
County here
and what about yeah I am a child of
Nassau County
okay we're we're sort of enemies but
let's see if we can work it through over
the next hour exactly they're the nicest
friends to real Long Islanders ever
how'd you lose the accent did you go did
you have the surgery too like I did you
know what's funny is people always say
to me that I sound more like I'm from
the Midwest or usually what they say to
me as I sound like yogi Yogi Bear or
Fozzie or something like that I don't
this is just the way I've always spoke
but I never had that real hardcore Long
Island accent though there are a few
words you know I say orange juice most
people say orange juice and what do you
put your pencils in at your desk when
you slide it out what are you learning
drawer but you're but I say draw it's a
draw
drop the arse at the end sorry but I've
been slowly trying to fix some of that
stuff but I have a great affinity to
actually to like the New York that real
New York accent that real Jersey accent
I'm watching them re watching The
Sopranos right now in the midst of
warranty and also and there's something
about that the the it's not just the way
they speak in terms of the tone but
there's like a real feeling to it
there's like a real like you're really
conveying something with the with the
language and I yeah yeah I would say
Long Islanders are the Canadians of New
York
nobody doesn't like Long Islanders right
so except our hockey team well I want to
get get to the book I want to talk some
big-picture stuff you probably don't
know this but this show is it's pretty
apolitical and I like to keep it that
way because I feel like there's so much
politics and the work that you do and
our mutual friends do on both sides of
the aisle but I also feel like you know
we need a safe space from from politics
in the sense that we need sports or
entertainment to largely be free abut so
I like to give this I always get my
little spiel is that you know there's no
the reason I like astronomy is that
there's no like Republican comets and
you know Democratic constellation yeah
that's right yes although yeah we may be
going there space force has its chance
so I wanted to just you know start off
with that look get into politics
inevitably because I think that's the
right function of your book and and in
your role in society as an influencer
and the media Titan over your over your
empire there but first I want to say the
book starts off with with you know a lot
of really personal details which you
know I'm sure we're yeah a little bit
unnerving perhaps to do especially as a
first-time author you know to come out
with your first book and then to really
spill your guts and you know Hemingway
used to say allegedly that the job of a
writer is to sit in front of a
typewriter and bleed and I wonder you
know when you work when you're going
through this since you have experienced
so much of the good and we'll get to the
good and the bad obviously later but was
that something you were you know kind of
you know you had any trepidation about
you know being so personal the book is
really endears the reader because you
are so personal and candid about your
life's affairs yeah so I will answer
your question but quickly I just want to
hit what you said there about a safe
space and that not everything should be
so political and all that because I
think it's an important part and
actually that's really how I end that's
a chapter 10 of the book in many ways
yeah you know it's funny because I don't
like the idea of safe spaces within a
university context where we're going to
protect kids from Dangerous Ideas I
actually think that's completely
antithetical to learning and every
reason that they should be on college
campuses however the spirit of what you
just said there that we should have
spaces where politics especially
partisan politics don't leak into
everything that is deep
deeply important because we live in a
time in the last five years where
politics has leaked into everything to
the point that you know that if you turn
on ESPN and you're watching SportsCenter
most likely there's something political
happening you're very rarely watching it
well now we're watching no sports
highlights but even without Corona
before that it was about identity
politics it was about racism it was
about standing for the flag or sitting
for the flag or a series of other things
and we desperately do need those places
to have sports or culture or art or
science things that we can discuss that
have nothing to do with the political
world so I just want to put that out
there that I'm loved that generally
speaking as to specifically to your
question that was the hardest part for
me when when I started writing this and
when I signed the deal originally and I
mentioned this right at the top of the
book I was gonna write why I left the
left and that that's a phrase that has
become attached to me because of a
Creager you video that I did a couple
years ago it has something like 20
million views and I was gonna write I
was a lefty now I'm not a lefty here's
what happened and as I was writing that
I started realizing I didn't want to
just write a book about what I'm against
I want to write a book that's about what
I'm for and that's really what don't
burn this book but came and then through
that this was and is my first book as
you said you know as I discuss things
with my editor and we tried to you know
piece together something that would you
know make cohesive sense and take take
everybody on a journey and not just be
sort of like bang bang bang like plow
through everything in in one very linear
shot it became more and more obvious
that I had to include some of the
personal stuff in yeah so you know I
think one of the things that I did
pretty effectively is I'm trying to get
people out of the political closet
because I really do believe that exists
I think there are good decent people who
refused to say what they think not
because they're racists or bigots or
haters or anything like that but just
because the positions they hold are a
little outside of the woke opinion of
the day and they're afraid that the mobs
gonna come get them so I like him that
to what it was like to be in the closet
sexually and I think that there's
actually a tremendous amount of overlap
there
I think that's gonna be one of the
things that I think will be most
effective in showing people why you have
to come out because it's it's very hard
to live one life it's hard to live one
life that makes sense that gives you
purpose and a little bit of joy and all
of that yeah what entik and you and all
that that's really hard to do it's as a
matter of fact it's your job as a person
to do a bit to do it and most of us
shirk that that responsibility but now
try to do it as two people as three
people as four people and the more that
you're in the closet for whatever it is
your sexuality your political thoughts
whatever a family secret whatever you're
in the closet for whatever you hide to
yourself and don'ts for the world it'll
end up owning you and I think a lot of
people are are seeing some version of
that right now so I tried to go into the
personal stuff as much as possible I
will tell you this the only chapter that
we ended up cutting from the book was
when I really really did a deep dive
into some further personal stuff and I
think I'm gonna ultimately save that for
another book because it was that was the
the trick to this was trying to write
something personal but also that really
was the real reason was to highlight the
ideas so you know there's always that
balance I think probably most authors
have to deal with with some version of
that that's right yeah I mean it struck
me as I was reading that and yeah you're
very candid as I say about you know
coming out of the closet and you know
the first thing that struck me is you
know for a comic you got pretty lousy
timing because we came in the closet on
9 10 2001 the eve before September 11
the awful events and then this book is
out during the greatest crisis you know
of our lives in many ways this like what
happens with your timing there you know
I gotta go make something they could
major life decision Dave you gotta let
us know a little bit ahead of time I
should be playing the market certainly
yeah that's incredible power no he's
actually yeah it's actually true I mean
technically it was it was 9/11 because
it was it was 12:30 a.m. on on 9/11 so
literally just you know announced seven
hours before the attacks and I lived in
New York City at the time and I was in
the Times Square subway station I'm sure
many of your viewers can picture the
exact spot right where the the shuttle
train that goes from Times Square to
Grand Central
right there with my buddy he lived in
Queens I lived on the Upper West so we
were saying goodbye and and I came out
to him which was the first person that I
had come out to and then you know seven
hours later a miracle is under attack
and and it truly that truly damaged me
you know like I had held this heart what
I thought was this horrific secret and
for so long and then I finally released
it into the universe the next thing I
know America is under attack and not
just America is under attack but the
city I live in no he's under attack and
it true I mean it sounds crazy but it
did some serious damage to my psyche
yeah I'm sure it did and you know I
think a lot of people are probably
grappling with this you know it were 20
years younger you know basically the
same age roughly you were at that time
and going through this is gonna be the
same kind of cathartic experience and I
you know I only hope that people can
deal with it and get the mental help
that they need and and deal with you
know the self-care etc and I want to get
into that because you have so many good
tips you know there are this podcast
into the impossible podcast about high
achievers high performers and kind of
how you get to this level of
intellectual you know the style that the
techniques the tactics that you use to
get to this you know really a really
prominent level but I think people can
also learn a lot from the personal and I
think that's that's you're to be
commended for that I do want to talk
about the book starting off you know
it's got blurbs from you know I called
the usual crew of of kind of the the
blogosphere it's that that you associate
with and Shapero your mentor Jordan
Peterson I do want to spend some time on
him and and many other luminaries but
one that's surprised me and they
surprised some of our listeners and the
readers is from Eckhart Tolle and he
said Dave Rubin is bridging as bridging
America's great divide he reminds us
that while we might not always agree
with the quote other we need to listen
capital letters to them Rubin has
mastered the vital skills of listening
and asking questions but do not serve an
ideological agenda I think a lot of
times you're unfairly you know portrayed
in this light in the media that you're
just you know all right the right wing
or you know you're kind of whatever the
analog is for for you know betraying
one's in one's class that they're
supposed to be representative of I think
you do a wonderful job of actually
people do take the time to listen to you
they'll find out the
you do have this you know catchphrase of
course classical liberalism I want to
get into that but you know as Eckhart
Tolle who is this master the author of
the you know world-famous best-selling
book the power of now he's really like a
spiritual guru and the people that he's
influenced are so diametrically opposed
to say the far the other people on the
cover not not that I don't know anything
about his politics and I'm happy that I
don't because I think we need this detox
and hopefully we'll get into that but
well I do want to talk about the book
you've got a copy behind you
I got a digital copy and I'm really
loved reading it you mentioned you spend
a little bit of time in the book talking
about the process of writing the book
and even the painstaking detail that you
went in on the cover and like you and
unlike the proverb I judge books by
their covers and and I think publishers
do too because that's the one thing
authors are not allowed to have much
control over you know they can have
their say and so forth but really the
publishers know this from it's their
livelihood to know that I want what does
the cover mean to you I want to I want
to share some feelings about what it
meant to me but what does it mean to you
it's a it's a unique and interesting
cover I'll have a picture of it
obviously in the video yeah so as you
know I'm in the midst of doing a ton of
press right now for this and I'll get
I'll drop something with you that I
haven't dropped publicly elsewhere
elusive this is exclusive so the so
there were several titles of the book as
I mentioned why I left the left was the
original working title and on the deal
that I signed that's what it said it was
going to be and then there was a day in
New York I I was in New York for some
meetings with the people at penguin
Random House and I was getting hit by
the media for exactly what you just
described he's a right-wing maniac and
all this stuff and it's like no matter
how many times I lay out what my lefty
cred is you know what I mean I described
in the book I'm begrudging Lee
pro-choice I happen to actually be gay
married I'm not just saying I'm for gay
marriage right right I'm for right we're
in the process of surrogacy right now
I'm in you know I'm against the death
penalty I'm for some level of public
education I could lay out all of my
lefty cred but unfortunately with the
new woke sort of hysterical left that
has that has arisen there is no room for
dissension over there so people just
associate now so associate me with the
which I don't mind being associated with
by the way I have found conservatives
and libertarians especially classical
liberals and cat people to be open and
willing to agree to disagree and there's
such fertile ground to battle out ideas
and I and I love that I absolutely love
that what I don't want to do is I don't
want to be called far-right I don't want
to be called all right things that the
New York Times has called me and a bunch
of other stuff but anyway I'm in New
York City taking all these meetings with
penguin and I had decided that I didn't
want to do the why I left the left book
and then I'm suddenly getting hit by the
media and they're calling me far-right
and the rest of it and I go into the
meeting with penguin and I said you know
what I've got a new title for the book I
want to call it right-wing lunatic
because my feeling was if this is what
these people are gonna say about me why
don't I write a book that's filled with
common sense filled with decent ideas
time-tested churned ideas that that
spread freedom and liberty and I'll
embrace this thing that people are
saying I am a right-wing lunatic so the
head of penguin said they all kind of
like it you know I'm sitting at this big
table and they all kind of bounce in
their heads up and down and then the the
head of penguin says well instead of
right-wing lunatic why don't we call it
the memoir of a right-wing lunatic and
that reminded me do you remember there
was a chubby chaser in the 80s or early
90s called memoirs of an invisible man
yes that would be lame because I always
liked that movie I like the title so I
thought that was it and then I was like
you know what if we're gonna go that far
let's even add and we were at one point
gonna call it the crazed rantings of a
right-wing lunatic and I left that
meeting saying that's what the title is
because I thought will embrace it it
flips it on a tag it on your truth on
your truth it will allow me to go into
interviews that maybe are hostile and
feel funny too because they're gonna
introduce me as you know the crazed
rantings of a right-wing lunatic and
then I'll be able to just lay out some
basic common-sense stuff and yada yada
yada to answer your question I brought
that idea home to my husband and he
could not believe that I was considering
such a psychotic title and then what
happened was when when we were mocking
up all sorts of books and penguin was
doing it and we were you know playing
around on Photoshop and stuff one of the
ideas we had regard
of what the title was was that we were
gonna have a red band around the book
that was gonna say don't burn this book
hmm and that you'd have to rip that to
open the book and suddenly it just hit
David actually you need to say well that
should be the title of the book and I
loved it I called my guys at CAA they
loved it I call Jordan Peterson he loved
it and we went with that I think it I
think it is really the right idea
because the point is that there's
there's a lot of stuff in here that's
gonna make people angry and I even make
a point at one point in the abortion
chapter I end it by saying you know now
that you all hate me let's move on but
the point is you shouldn't burn it you
don't have to love it you don't have to
love everything I write here you don't
know if you agree with everything I say
here but but these are the ideas I'm
presenting and let's live in a kamar
time when when book-burning yeah you
know done that's that's sort of what I
wanted to share with you my impression
of the book and maybe it was you know
subliminal or whatever maybe it's
colored by my you know affinity for
science fiction and being you know
co-directing the arthur c clarke center
which obviously arthur c clarke was a
master of science nonfiction but also
science fiction 2000s there yeah and one
of my favorite books as a kid I was
Fahrenheit 451 and this is Ray
Bradbury's classic book from the 1950s
and you know I don't think it's possible
to spoiler a book that's not all you've
been talking about the matrix a lot on
your show and you're like I don't even
have to say spoiler because you haven't
seen in 20 years you're here it's not
going to be a spoiler for you but but
that book 451 is a dystopian novel that
ray wrote in the context of the McCarthy
era book burnings that were going on or
you know desires on the far right and
literally during the McCarthy era to to
burn books and he thought of it as a as
a commentary against that notion
it's allegedly the temperature he was
told at which paper begins to burn and
and the end of the book also cun and
again no spoiler alerts needed but but
but the the book concludes with a call
you know clarion call that people should
instead of burning books and having you
know these these buildings where books
are burned they should instead build a
building filled with
mirrors and so that society can look at
themselves and I think you know we're
spending so much time nowadays you know
looking in the black mirrors and you
talked a lot about that and how does
that tie into you know I thought it was
sort of a nice callback to that the book
you know don't burn this book it
reminded me of that that this could be
dystopian you know if people I don't
think people are literally going to burn
your book but but the notion of it as a
psychological concept I think you know
there is a there's a certain amount of
hostility but back then as I said it was
really the McCarthy era far right and I
wonder if you see that coming from these
little black mirrors that we all have
does that now kind of manifest itself in
a completely different way decentralized
you know to spread out and and how a
society interacts with it to effectively
not burn but cancel this book like don't
cancel this book that's a great question
and there's so much there and I'm a big
sci-fi guy too and so much of the way I
view the world is because I don't want
us to end in a dystopian future I don't
want the machines to take over from
terminator I don't want to have to end
up living on Mars like Total Recall or
being the battery like in the matrix or
or or you know one of the beautiful
things about Fahrenheit 451 is that many
of the people that were doing the
burning were secretly having thoughts
that were free thoughts that's right and
in many ways that caused them to do more
burning because they had to hide their
you know I mean this is there's a very
religious sort of repress yourself and
then destroy the other sort of notion in
that I would say I'm I'm very you know
it's funny I describe myself as a world
weary optimist I don't think you could
do roughly what I do for a living
meaning putting your thoughts out there
talking to people you agree and disagree
with and being very public about what
you think if you didn't have some level
of optimism because the hope is that by
doing all of this taking like the full
Gestalt of everything that I do that
maybe I'll have elevated the world a
little bit maybe I will have done a
little bit of what those incredibly kind
words that Eckhart Tolle wrote about me
maybe a little bit of that will
translate into the real world but I am
worried
especially now especially now as we are
all trapped at home and we still don't
know how much longer we're going to be
trapped at home yeah that the dystopian
version of the future in many ways is
coming true in front of us right now
we're all trapped at home we all know
that big tech has a endless cascade of
problems and yet we now are more reliant
on big tech than ever so a year ago if
you were arguing well big tech should be
regulated or we need more competition or
whatever that might be or the algorithms
are coming to get us or we have to worry
about shadow banning or D boosting or
all of these things if you were worried
about that a year ago you know it's very
interesting because very few people are
talking about it now and yet now big
tech and the world as it is just pushed
us all war into the matrix right we're
we're in it now more than ever you
cannot all of your communication the way
we are doing this is through the big
tech pipes you can't meet your friend
for a beer right now
you can't go bowling with a couple of
your buddies and talk about life if
you're a political you know your
presidential candidate whatever you are
you can't hold a rally anymore so big
tech and the idea gatekeepers have way
more control over us right this second
than they did five weeks ago that is a
huge problem and something we have to be
thinking about what I keep tweeting is
we're all playing a fixed game and we're
pretending that the rules aren't fixed
we have no idea what big tech is doing
to manipulate us to make our feeds seem
this way or hide certain people or boost
other people but we know that they do it
you know Twitter's Terms of Service
actually has shadow Manning as of
January 1st of this year in their Terms
of Service they are telling us we can we
can suppress certain people and amplify
other people now if Twitter and Facebook
and YouTube and the rest of it are the
true highways of information and
communication of the future well this is
where I see a lot of conservatives
saying we need regulation that now the
libertarian side of me doesn't want to
do that and I started a tech company
locals calm that I think is doing a nice
job of cleaning up some of this mess but
these are the conversations we should be
having right now because any of the
things that that you care about about
science and open inquiry in free thought
right now they're super dependent on a
couple systems that aren't that friendly
to that stuff and I think our eye is off
the ball right now we're sort of just
not paying attention to it and by the
way there's good reason that we're not
we're not because our immediate lives
feel crazy we can't go out we're worried
about going to the supermarket and
making sure we have enough food and
house and suddenly the big tech thing
doesn't seem as important but I think
the longer this goes on and and the if
the after-effects the second and third
order effects I think are gonna be
massive and we should be thinking about
it at the same time yeah so another you
know kind of thing that came to mind is
I will look at your book and read
through it as you know also involves
burning and and heat and as I'm sure
you're familiar from your extensive
studies of the laws of thermodynamics
which state that oh yeah ii only when
I'm not studying string theory my that's
right well we need all the all the
stringing string as we can get nowadays
so the second law of thermodynamics in
particular says that the entropy or
chaos or disorder of a system
you know cannot decrease over time it
can only go in one direction and you
know in the book and and and publicity
for the book you talk about liberalism
and you say defend liberal liberalism
while you still can
time is running out to defend individual
rights limited government and free
expression so you know given that the
law of you know conservation of or the
law of second law of thermodynamics says
the things are going to get more and
more chaotic
is it really you know concomitant with
that that the that we can't go back if
we lose these freedom of speech rights
that we enjoy today ah that's a good one
there's a lot there this is where are
you familiar with michael malice by any
chance who i've had on the show a couple
times i've heard him on your show but i
i'm not i don't recall exactly that so
so michael malice is what I would
describe as sort of a extreme
libertarian sort of like an and cap type
and his his constant argument is just
that but the things always spinning out
of control and that and that
conservatives even really aren't
conserving they're just sort of slowing
the speed limit along the way to chaos
so it may something like that
I've sort of come around to that general
belief but it doesn't mean that it's not
a reason to do it I think we have to
preserve
good ideas for as long as we can the two
hundred plus years of the United States
have been some of the freest most
prosperous years that humanity has ever
seen actually all of them all of the
years have been and more people for more
walks of life come to the United States
and flourish and still do to this day
and even right now as as a certain set
of people in the United States scream
that that Hitler is in charge which is
absurd
nobody leaves they don't leave you know
and and one of the things is that if you
wanted to leave under Hitler he wouldn't
let you leave right that causes a lot of
debts Trump's not forcing anyone to stay
and people still do want to come here
and the reason for that is that the
ideas of classical liberalism the idea
of individual rights everyone is treated
the same under the law it doesn't matter
it doesn't mean that some people aren't
born with more it doesn't mean that some
people aren't born luckier it doesn't
mean that some people won't work harder
or a series of other things that make up
the human experience but equal laws
which by the way as brilliant as our
founders were and as as incredible and
revolutionary truly as our founding
documents were it doesn't mean it was
all perfect at the time right we had
slaves and then we freed the slaves
women couldn't vote and then women could
vote we had Japanese internment
temporarily I mean we've done bad things
but the arc has consistently always with
with virtually no exception the arc has
always bent towards more true justice
for more people now I don't mean social
justice I mean justice in terms of
equality of opportunity that's what we
have right now and we but we are running
out of room to defend it because in look
right now right now regardless of what
you think about how we should be on
lockdown or quarantine or regardless of
what you think about coronavirus as a
whole right now the Fourth Amendment in
effect is suspended we don't have the
right to assemble right now now we
should be having a discussion about that
can that go on forever in the name of
public safety I don't know exactly what
the answer is there but we should be we
should be talking about it but very few
people are talking about it right now
let's say you are a let's say you
thought coronavirus was a complete hoax
and a government grab for power I don't
believe that but should you be allowed
to voice those opinions on social media
without being banned and is that a
violation of the First Amendment even
though social media companies aren't
necessarily part of the government
although there are a lot of ties there I
think that's certainly a conversation
worth having so all of these things lead
to what your question is which is if
this thing is just spinning sort of more
and more out of control and right now it
does feel like our system is in this odd
place of it it feels like a Jenga set
basically our system right now right
precarious yeah we're it's in a
precarious place and by the way not just
our system I don't you know I talk about
a lot of this stuff through an American
context but of course this is a
worldwide situation right now but what
we have to be doing is defending the
right ideas when it's the hardest to
defend them and and these are not you
know the ideas that you just mentioned
these are pretty simple things
individual rights and limited government
so that you can do what your with your
life what you wish this is pretty basic
stuff and we just have to reignite that
within yeah cuz I think they understand
it they actually are drawn to it which
is a beautiful thing what do you think
about the rise of of this movement kind
of a back reaction in some sense your
book Michael schirmer's book who had in
the show last week giving the devlins
too and it works but and Shapiro's were
a book that they kind of are really this
full-throated advocacy for things that
we used to take for granted you know the
the First Amendment you know and you say
in the fourth amendment these these
aspects of the former America and yet
you know many we don't perceive you know
jackbooted thugs coming from Washington
DC I mean it's pretty darn nice I mean
California's you know if you have to be
sheltering at home it's one of the best
places in the world I think to do so
obviously I haven't left and the Sun the
sun is shining today I'm not exactly I
mean don't tell my boss you know Gavin
Newsome you know I'd work at the
University of California even if he
didn't pay this place so you know what
is there a danger and kind of
overblowing you know all these books all
these works and as erudite as they are
that people are just not going to take
it seriously because you know they look
around their life they say there's no
thugs you know cramming down you know
disk pulling my
my Ethernet port I I don't have a
million followers like Dave Rubin so you
know I mean poor poor Dave Rubin you
know he's gonna have 999,000 because of
shadow benning's
man there's a lot there you're nailing
it with the questura no you're giving me
to Long Islanders you know it's no I I
mother custom no I love it though
because you're giving me the stuff that
sort of lays right underneath the the
idea set which is which is I think what
a good interviewer should do so is there
a risk in that that because right now
the government isn't running to our
houses and stopping us that maybe we're
over blowing it or something like that
well my first answer would be that if
you look at sort of this crew some of
the names that you just mentioned there
so Shapiro and Michael Shermer and if
you threw in sam harris and jordan
peterson he said we'll get to and a few
other people
what an interesting diverse group of
thinkers now these job they happen to be
white men some of them are straight some
of them are gay it's or Heather McDonald
in there know when we could throw
Heather McDonald we could throw I
honestly we could throw Douglas Murray
we could throw Maajid Nawaz we could
throw Thomas Sol I mean there there's a
million people so I'm just giving you a
couple names here let's say but what you
have there is true intellectual
diversity so even I'll even go with just
the two you mentioned up top so Shapiro
and Shermer Shapiro is an absolute
believer I mean he believed his
worldview is an Orthodox Jewish
worldview Michael Shermer is a skeptic
he's a he's a former born-again
Christian who is now an atheist and a
skeptic these guys shouldn't have that
much in common except in that their
existential view of the world is
completely different but what they've
realized is that as organic beings here
on planet earth right now the rights
that are protecting them to think
completely differently are the rights of
the individual and of basically of
limited government right that's so I
think something interesting has happened
here where yes and I talked about this
in the book by the way but I am not
worried
my major worry at the moment is not that
the government is going to be the thing
that comes in silences me we should
always be wary of that and most bad
things that have happened over time
happened because of bad governments what
I am more worried about is the average
person that your
talking about who just sort of checks
out they just decide I'm not gonna say
what I think because I don't want to
deal with the social media mob I don't
want to deal with the BuzzFeed or
Huffington Post box in peace and that
what they will do is they will slowly
disconnect their thoughts from their
daily life and then you sort of are just
a robot and then you're sort of very
easily controlled and that's what I'm
worried about so the premise of the
question is a good one because yes is it
more obvious when they go after a sort
of bigger name and then it's like you
could watch that guy and be like oh so
what he's not getting as many retweets
as he used to but that's not really what
it's about and the best example I can
give you is why is it that virtually
every week Media Matters leads a
campaign to get Tucker Carlson off the
air now I have no doubt that you have
some disagreements with Tucker cross
politically for sure and I do too by the
way I go on the show I go on a show
basically every week now he wants to
intervene in big tech I don't that is a
fundamental great place to have
disagreement and we do it just we do it
respectfully but there's a reason
they're going after Tucker and it's not
just to shut down Tucker it's to signal
to all of the people who agree to Tucker
see if we can get him we've got you and
that's why whenever they go after Tucker
I defend him because it's like we need
to signal to people that they can't
destroy all and that to me is you know
we study imagination curiosity
creativity here at the arthur c clarke
center for human imagination and you
know one of the best most delicious
things you can do in life is have a
respectful conversation and with someone
you don't agree with if you're just
talking in the echo chamber you know as
a scientist as a lay person it's
incredibly boring I was I was talking
with a friend on Saturday afternoon and
a walk six feet apart of course if
you're listening Gavin but he and he was
saying you know there's seem to be you
know almost like a law of physics you
know another started to drop so much
physics on you today but you know a
string theory master like you can handle
it I'm also working on the theory of
everything by the way I should have it
done by the end of the day okay good
well you might get scooped I had a guest
on yesterday who's already published his
results oh well we'll leave it leave it
to you
publish but he said you know I believe
in sort of a concept of the conservation
of outrage which is that you know if you
look back in the in the you know 1400s
when there were serfs and they would
rebel against feudal lords it was
outrageous the mass populace against the
very few gatekeepers and it was the
protests against the Divine Right of
Kings you know that came about the
populace against the gatekeeper then it
was you know the French Revolution they
are stock receipt now it and then it
became Washington you know the pot but
now it's it's sort of the the opposite
the gatekeepers have become this
distributed you know mass and the net
amount of outrage has to be maintained
just like energy cannot be created or
destroyed outrage cannot be destroyed
you can't reduce it again this one-way
ratchet and pawl that cannot be reversed
and and I wonder you know is that is
that a symptom of of what's going on in
in society as a whole that yes they may
not come for you you know today because
you're not they brew and listeners not
they brew but but but tomorrow they may
come for you know come for you but you
know I think I think looking at this
need that people have and it's never
been easier to communicate and that's
why one of the things I love most about
your book is you basically go through
this process of describing this very
virtuous aspect of your life which is
called digital detox and you you take
off the whole month of August is sort of
a monthly sabbatical and and even you
advocate doing it weekly as well and I
wonder you know one of your rules though
you know for life to quote your mentor
is as you know take to spend time with
your physical you know neighbors in in
meat world you know in real life but you
know it's so hard to do that nowadays
fact it might be illegal in certain
jurisdictions so yeah I mean this is
such a crazy time but I wonder can we
talk a little bit about that because one
of the you know as I said I like there
to be a politics free zone I like the
this notion and I'm also you know
practicing Jew I'm not as I'm not as I
don't do Jew as much as Ben does but but
but the same token it's incredibly
important to my life the meaning my
family my children my wife how do you
how did this you know kind of come to
you and have you seen the benefits and
what are the challenges to maintaining
this as I said very virtuous but it is
challenging
do you maintain it if some tips to our
listeners about how to do that how to
deal with it in this I'll first give a
tip of the hat to the Jewish portion of
this which I am Jewish as well and I
tweeted you know when every now and
again I take the I try to take the
weekends off off of social media at
least so I'll still right now in Corona
in the last six weeks I haven't been
fully taking the weekends off I'd done
some version of it because with the
Rubin Report community we watch a movie
together and then we do is zoom call it
and a few other things everybody that's
seen from sorry to remember me that
scene from airplane the movie airplane
where the air traffic controller looks
like I took pick the wrong month to give
up cocaine look like I picked the wrong
week you think it's not August
it's not August for Dave Rubin right
exactly although I would do it right now
if it was August and I'm really looking
forward to this August for many reasons
but you know sometimes on Fridays
whereas the day it gets towards the end
of the day around five o'clock I'll
tweet out you know taking off for the
weekend I'll see you on Monday and and
Shapiro has tweeted at me a couple times
and say you do know that the Jews have
been doing this for about five thousand
years on it called Shabbat we're all
shomer Shabbos down right so I tell him
I tell him I'm doing an extended 48-hour
Shabbat for the most time for the most
part now beats him on the weekends but
my real reasoning for doing this I saw
I've done three summers of August off
the grid and when I did it the first
time I really just wanted to try it it
was just like wow my life has been so
enriched by YouTube and Twitter and
Facebook and all of this stuff and I and
I get to do what I want for a living and
I've started a successful company and
I'm have purpose and I'm doing something
that I'm really proud of and it's it's
often hard and it comes with a lot of
slings and arrows as I as I write about
in the book but so much of my life is in
this digital space and as you reference
before with the matrix it's like the
idea of the matrix without giving the
spoiler away is that we are our physical
selves are our carbon-based selves will
become the batteries for the digital
world and in many ways that is what's
happening right now the digital world is
now looming larger in many ways than
what it seems like our physical world is
and you can really see that in a day of
corona we are spending more and more
part I'm staring into those black
mirrors that you referenced and that I'm
fascinated by that so I thought three
years ago let me just take a summer a
month in the summer because August is
when things calm down a little bit more
and let's see what happens and I
literally locked my phone in a safe no
TV no no nothing the one thing that I
did have was that my car does have GPS
in it so I could still get places I have
terrible sense of direction but that
really was it and you know what you
quickly find is you know I was trying to
avoid news it's very hard to avoid news
because wherever there is a muted
television CNN is on you go to you go to
the gym you go to the gym and I'd have
to wear a low hat and I do cardio
looking like this because I didn't you
know they've got TVs up there you go to
a burger joint and CNN is on or at or
ESPN is on and I wanted to just avoid
everything and and in the three summers
that I've done it I have managed to
absolutely avoid everything you know
fortunately I have an assistant and
people that work for me that make sure
that if there were massive fires with
the company that things are taken care
of and the one thing that we do do is
David does my husband does a version of
this with me but doesn't really do it
because he's running the companies but
he'll try to only check his phone maybe
once a night just to make sure
everything's okay so whatever my point
is that you don't need to set a rule
like I'm absolutely not gonna touch
anything and it's gonna be for a month
and I'm going to avoid everything and
all that that's very very hard to do but
I do say you know if maybe you don't
have to do a month but maybe do from
Christmas to New Year's you know and
everyone kind of shuts down at that time
of the year it's the time to be you it
doesn't matter what religion you are
it's it's sort of time to be with family
or shut down just the last week of the
summer if you can and if you can't do
even either of those try it occasionally
on the weekend start four Saturdays
maybe and then add it to Sundays or the
other way around and I think what you
will find is that it will give your
brain a chance to reset and I and I also
offer some other little tips like don't
bring your phone into the bedroom yeah
you you the first thing that you do in
the morning should not be looking at
social media before you brush your teeth
or have a glass of water and certainly
the last thing that you do at night and
there are Studies on this by the way and
because of the light that
shouldn't be the last thing that you're
doing I mean you should either read a
book or Tucker yourself out outside of
your bedroom and then just go into your
room to go to sleep yeah so I think all
of these things I'm not an expert in any
of this and I don't think that we've
fully booked we've been handed something
awesome here it's like being handed fire
at the beginning and fires pretty great
right you can cook some stuff and it can
warm you up fire can also burn you and
it can also burn the house down yeah and
I think we have to start looking at tech
like that it is it is a tool and you
don't want it to burn the whole house
down while you're warming up the place
and don't burn the book as well and
don't burn that book burns at 451 that's
right I want to move it mainly uh you
know touchy subject for you and you and
feel free you don't have to answer we
can oh I will answer it out so you've
written a book you come highly endorse
from from your friend Jordan Peterson
who's become you know incredibly
controversial but incredibly successful
you talk about the power power of having
mentors and you talk about the the image
that he's cultivated and how it matched
the reality that you observed as the
opening act on a year-long tour with
Jordan during his twelve twelve rules
for life world tour everywhere around
the world Australia and back and in the
US and many shows even brought them up
onstage to do a comedy sets quite it's
quite touching to see that he's you're
easier mentor easier he's your friend it
seems like he's a little bit of a father
figure to you as he is to you know
presumably many people around the world
I've never met him I haven't had the
chance to read the book yet but I know
how influential he was given that he
talks so much about self care and given
that you have obviously become
enlightened to this notion of taking
care of yourself your husband hopefully
soon your child to come that that that
being aware of self care do you feel
like he let he let you down in any way I
mean he he's had struggles with
addiction and and there's and he's been
very candid about that and and his
children as well I wonder how did that
affect you when you found out about that
if you care to talk about it yeah I'm
happy to talk about the one-word answer
to the question is do I feel like he let
me down it's no without question but I
will I will expand
that obviously first up you know when we
were on tour for that year plus and it
was a hundred twenty stops in in
something like 23 countries something
like that Jordan was very open that he
was taking a very small amount of benzo
of I think klonopin for anti-anxiety he
would talk about it on stage so this
wasn't first off you know I think a lot
of people think he was like secretly
doing drugs secretly a pill-popper or
something like that and then publicly
presenting something else so first off I
want to be a hundred percent clear that
is simply not true that's number one
number two we were in the middle of the
country I think we were in Iowa we were
having lunch and you know he does this
carnivore diet so he the guy has a rib
eye for breakfast usually a rib eye for
lunch and two rib eyes or a tomahawk for
dinner steak that's it it was the only
Canadian the only Canadian who does that
a rug Linnaeus in text but we were at
lunch at a steak house I think in Iowa
when he got the call from the doctor and
his wife that his wife had been
diagnosed with terminal cancer I was at
lunch with him and I and I heard the
phone call eventually I walked away from
the table I saw this man not only I mean
try to imagine the incredible highs of
Fame the rigor of traveling like crazy
the media hit pieces and the good stuff
the audience is cheering and the
protesters I mean the entire up-and-down
craziness benny finds out his wife has
terminal cancer he's traveling sometimes
with her sometimes without her I mean
the extraordinary truly extraordinary
and by the way you have to keep in mind
that this isn't a guy this isn't like a
comedian or an actor right it's he's
going on the road right but that was
chasing Fame yeah you know I mean like a
comedian or an actor they're usually
chasing Fame and then one day if they're
lucky they become famous this is a guy
who is a clinical psychologist who was
writing writing books that are pretty
pretty dense idea books right so he
didn't chase this thing and suddenly he
had this thing anyway adding all of that
up and then and then the fact that his
his wife was diagnosed with his terminal
cancer he did I didn't know it at the
time but he did end up upping the amount
of been
I don't want to even go into that any
theater suffice to say that people can
have an adverse reaction you can
actually appetite up a reaction where
you up it and you get the reverse where
it's supposed to be an ting anxiety and
then it becomes what I will tell you is
this I did see him a couple months ago
he's doing better it's a struggle it's a
real struggle and more than anything
else and I think this will directly
answer your question he's a human he's a
human the guy wrote an incredible book
I've got it right there 12 rules for
life and maps a meaning even before that
he wrote a life giving people what he
views as a human the best tools to live
their best life it does not mean that
he's Jesus or that he is somehow this
perfect machine that is impervious to
the human condition yeah that being said
I have no doubt that as he's going
through what he's gone through that he's
using his own rules to fix himself
so I think that's part of it and and by
the way that's why we shouldn't even
though I think that you shouldn't try to
find a mentor we do need people to map a
future version of ourselves after
Michael Shermer by the way who you spoke
to last week and who introduced us um I
love Michael he's been a from the first
time I had him on the show I thought
this is someone who thinks clearly we
have a couple of disagreements it
doesn't even matter what they are but he
said I know him to be a good man and an
interesting person all those things so
we need people in the world that we can
map that sort of thing after but what
you should be always wary of thinking
that they're perfect because there are
no perfect people and and that the you
know the simplest way of saying this
would be can we can you separate the art
from the artist you know I mean that's
really it like you can you can make a
piece of art that's absolutely brilliant
and could express a deep deep truth it
doesn't mean the perfect person that
painted it often the opposite and it's
quite often the opposite yeah in the
book and this and this I don't
necessarily want to get it too but you
obliquely kind of comment about you know
fatherhood and in your life now that
your and your husband are planning this
but you're also kind of obliquely
reference your own father again I don't
wanna get into that but I think part of
being mature is is that recognition that
you just mentioned about your parents
about about your mentors about your
heroes that they are human beings and
this book is kind of the hero's journey
of how you went in on this role and and
and this in this journey and part of the
hero's journey you may know you know
from Star Wars or whatever is that yeah
your parents you have to leave your Yoda
and and you have to become on your own
and I wonder looking at Jordan looking
at this experience from someone who all
appearances seemed so earnest and
interested in helping people and yet has
such vitriol as you said you know coming
back at him and he's yet very poised and
dignified as he talked about in the book
from his dress to his you know to his
mannerisms the way he treats the waiter
in the cat there's a story there's a
passage in in George Orwell's Animal
Farm from Benjamin the donkey and he
says the donkey is being envied I think
by the pig or something and the pig says
you're so lucky you got this awesome
tail and and the donkey says yeah the
Lord gave me a tail to swat away the
Flies but I'd rather not have the Flies
and not need the tail and I wonder
looking at Jordan looking at these
people that you you know like do you
worry about getting too big or getting
cultivating you know such a such a
persona and oral through your projects
your company and through the ribbon
report do you worry that there is a
flipside of this maybe you won't be able
to take the Sabbath this this detox and
and do the self-care that you need or
especially as you bring a child into the
world you know it's awesome
responsibility and it's an incredibly
maturing thing hopefully experience for
for parents do you worry about the
implications your sort of you know
attaching them you won't be able to do
as much you'll have to be you know if in
order for you to say yes to things like
going on a world tour or whatever you'll
have to say no to this precious little
infinite you know spark of love and how
are you prepared to cope with it or is
that something you know do I think about
it all the time he all the time you know
just related to the let's say the fame
part of this look I'm not gonna sit here
and say I have no ego and I'm not gonna
say here and it's you know it's not nice
when you know when I get a lot of
retweets or that you know already we
know the book has sold really well
before it's even out or all of those
things I'm not gonna pretend those
things aren't nice I like when people
come up to me on the street and at the
supermarket and whatever not every
moment of it you know first off you
this is an interesting thing for you
know we live in a time where there's so
much hate online but I can truly tell
you that I think with with 1/2 of an
exception anyone who's ever come up to
me in real life at a supermarket or at a
movie theater or at a pizza joint
whatever it is these are these are great
people who just want to say hi and say
oh you know you had a little something
to do with my life or I dig what you're
doing or whatever it is I love all of
that but I can tell you that as someone
that is I suppose on that on that up
side of the bigger thing I am worried
about that at some level like I don't
really have a desire to be more famous
than I am right now I don't have like
that hole in me that needs to be filled
if anything I would prefer the reverse
actually I really like the work that I'm
doing and I view the public part of it
look I'm on camera when I interview
people I'm on camera you put a book out
there you're gonna be seen and read and
heard and all of those things but in a
way it's almost like a it's it's a nice
bonus but you don't want it to be it's
like a dopamine yeah that's the thing
it's a treat but you don't want to
indulge on the treat all the time and
and I hope that I'll be able to navigate
it properly you know fortunately because
of some of the people who we've
mentioned here I've seen some guys go
through this beast before and then I've
seen some of the mistakes and I've seen
some of the successes and I'll try to
navigate it the best I can but yes will
it affect all of the things of my future
life about how much I can be around for
a child or or I mean you know things
that you don't want to talk about safety
concerns and all sorts of other stuff
these are all these are all things that
that I do bounce around and think about
but but I guess what I would say is more
than anything else whatever that
whatever the concerns are whatever the
trepidations are the worries are none of
them would supersede my desire to do
what I think I'm supposed to do II I
wouldn't let a fear beat me out of doing
what I think I'm supposed to be doing
and that is just this and I think that's
that's really the point of life you know
what I mean you have nothing to fear but
fear itself right what does that really
mean it means you're supposed to go
you're supposed to move forward in life
fear is what can stop you it doesn't
mean that that having some level of fear
fear by the way can push you right but
what you don't want is fear to be here
and you're pushing through in the second
you get to fear to cau away because you
don't know what's over there and yeah
you know I'll continue to do the best I
can but I think that's all that anyone
with their head on straights doing yeah
I think you're right and just a touch on
that I learned from the great rabbinical
sage Carrie Underwood that which is
actually true I actually looked this up
the most often repeated phrase that God
tells either Moses or the Israelites in
the Old Testament in the Torah is do not
fear and it's interesting you know do
not fear the stranger do not fear the
ant you know and serve its etc and I
think that is true fear is an impediment
and just to your point I read somewhere
Bill Murray once was asked you know I
want to be famous you know and he's like
and do you have any tips to be famous
and he was like try being rich first
because being rich you know I hope to
find that out someday but I hope you do
too well very quickly for people that
maybe don't want to read the entire
Bible to get that point across you could
just watch what I think his Albert
Brooks is best movie defending your lion
your life yeah and the whole purpose of
the book sorry of the movie is that he
ends up in purgatory he's dead and the
only way he can move forward is that he
has to prove and the movie is about a
trial of his life he has to prove that
he's conquered fear it's it's a it's an
absolutely wonderful movie I think it's
his best movie and and that concept that
you have to defeat fear I think it's a
very human thing yeah I wonder I have
about eight to ten questions or so do
you have time to go for another God
whatever my guy said all right okay
guess I'll speed it up a little bit yeah
I want to talk about tactics now so we
discuss your digital detox tactics which
I think could be a book in itself and
what about public speaking how did you
prepare your you done stand-up comedy do
you think there's sort of this meta
skill stack that you know goes into you
know it's tips you know things to be a
comedian involve convincing emotion
connection are those tactics that you
can then bring into writing or the con
is that your what tactics um yeah you
know it's interesting cuz I think
everybody has a different skillset
everybody has a different toolkit for me
you know I could just get up there I was
never nervous on stage really I'm not
saying I never had any nerves but like
it the nervousness or when you hear
you'll hear comedians or public speakers
talk about the nerves and they couldn't
get on his age they couldn't get out of
their bed they were freaked out I never
had any of that I would kind of walk on
stage and in a weird way I felt very
empowered and I even do now and when I
was on tour with Jordan and you know the
PA announcer would say now the host of
the Rubin report Dave Rubin and 3,000
people applaud as you walk out there
with a microphone
what an incredible feeling that is I
mean that that I remember the first
night did it happen because I mentioned
this in the book that it was a surprise
that I was it was a test show nearly
that Jordan was running out here and I
said to him right before you want me to
come on and make a couple jokes and he
said yeah and I went up and they
announced my name the crowd didn't know
I was gonna be there I had no idea if
these people even knew me right Jordan's
way more famous and important than I am
and once that first time happened and I
felt that it filled me up and and you
can run with that so I would say it's
really it's different for everybody and
you really have stage fright well you
got to work through that I think the
best thing you can do and I always try
to do this in stand-up and I try to do
this in everything I'm doing including
an interview or or when I'm being
interviewed or when I'm interviewing
someone else is I try to be as present
as possible yeah and if I'm really doing
it well I'm not even trying because I
just are yeah and I don't you know when
I give talks now one of the things that
I was most impressed by with Jordan is
he would give a different
hour-and-a-half lecture every night it
is incredible
he would give a route sometimes he would
talk about all 12 rules sometimes he
would talk about one rule sometimes he
would talk about no rules you talk about
what his day was like and one of the
things that I think I was able to
incorporate in the last year and a half
post working with him on this is that
when I give talks right now usually I
don't think about it during the day if I
have to give an hour talk let's say at a
college I don't think about it all
during the day for a few minutes before
the talk I kind of just take a breath
and I'm like what is on my mind right
now and if I get for me if I get that
starting point right just the basic
starting point of where I want to go
then at the end point it gets there I
usually I never have an ending set in
mind when I give a talk I have the
starting point and I'll figure out how
to get there
he built a parachute on the way down
yeah which maybe maybe in some ways but
you know what maybe that's not the
safest thing to do but for me it's I
think it's the most expressive to get
the best Southam yet that being said
there are some people that are that are
perfectly good public speakers who I
hear that give the same speech over and
over I just can't do it yeah I just
can't do it and that's what I mean about
the toolkit and people being wired
I remember hearing you know this words
of praise from a comedian about the
comedian louis c.k and you know he's had
his problems but this isn't relevant to
that but he said something like guy
writes new material every year I was
like you know what would happen if I
wrote new material every year you know
it's called unemployment every year
that's that's pretty impressive but
there's a great moment there's a great
moment in the Seinfeld when the show
ended he did a documentary called
comedian comedian it's about him getting
back into stand-up and there's a moment
where he's in the car with Garry
Shandling and they were really best
friends and brothers in comedy and
they're talking about their process and
Jerry you know he's got his notes and it
and and you know they're just every word
every inflection every it's all just
there and he says Gary what about you
and Gary pulls out this crumpled piece
of paper and he's like I don't know I
scribbled this down and it's like
they're both brilliant comics but they
have they have different brains all
right I think one tip on to say in the
interest of time that I've take to heart
and I agree with wholeheartedly that you
brought up that you learned from Jordan
your mentor Jordan is to dress up you
know the feeling that you had of putting
on you know look you don't have to dress
a career in you know shorts and the
flip-flops are all I know and you talked
about that's your basic you know a
plumage when you were off offstage and
even sometimes on stage but you learn
from him that you know part of it is
looking the part and looking the being
professional even if your job is the
professional gesture so I thought that
was one of the hacks the talking points
that they'll make people it just breeds
an air of confidence when a man or woman
gets on stage to get to give a talk you
know yeah I want to finish up with what
I call the the final five just a
rapid-fire series of questions that are
kind of standard across from my
listeners so the first thing is that
I've always felt that you know as close
as we have to kind of DNA
at least as as you know creative Homo
sapiens is our books you know and books
have this ability to be transmitted our
ideas and if not our DNA are our memes
if not our genes into the future so one
question I'd be curious about would you
rather have a hundred readers of this
book or a thousand readers of this book
a year from now or one reader of this
book a hundred years from now or a
thousand years from now should should we
make it that long I love the meme and
gene conversation right because I think
it's just so cool some people can spread
their genes some people can spread their
memes I love looking at the world
through that yeah hopefully I'm
hopefully I'm gonna do both if
everything works if everything works out
right good luck yes I would say right
now because of the what I would say is a
truly unique time right now I would want
as many people as possible to take this
book in right now I think the thing that
I'm most proud of is I wrote this thing
way before Korona but so many of the
issues that I'm talking about in this
book I mean look just I'll just give you
one because I know you wanna do this
quick I mean the states rights issue
that I'm that I so focus on here which
is it which is what our founders wanted
a month ago nobody was talking about
states rights everyone's talking about
states rights now because there's an
actual crisis you know so I want people
to read this now so that they can think
about how we're gonna move forward
clearly because we better think about it
otherwise we're in a lot of trouble and
speaking of you know readers not not in
the in the deep future but in the
present if you had a choice you had to
choose one group who would you rather
read this book cover-to-cover
you know the haters or the fans I think
the fans deserve the book okay I think
the fans deserve a little cover for some
of their ideas and they and they deserve
it I'm always down to talk to the haters
if they'll do it respectfully although
they don't they don't often but I've
given enough to the haters yeah so last
couple of questions what do you most
pessimistic about you said you're kind
of a guarded optimist you know you're
three-quarters of a glass full perhaps
what are you most pessimistic about well
I'm just worried that
with all of the success that we've had
as a society that the Western world has
had that may be the sad depressing truth
is that we've grown too fat on our
success we've got grown too fat on our
our wondrous prosperity and that the
Guardians will be at the gate and too
loosely quote Douglas Murray will be
debating what gender pronoun to call
them that we will have so lost the goal
that our eye will be looking elsewhere
as all the bad ideas come in and I think
maybe that actually gets to your earlier
question about why are all these books
suddenly out there why are these voices
so the other zeitgeist because maybe
this is the last stand maybe hmm that
would be a pessimist I guess so
if you were optimist if you were a
pessimist don't ask you what you're
optimistic about but instead the
penultimate question is a favorite quote
of mine from the great thinker writer
Soren Kierkegaard who said that life can
only be understood backwards but you
must live it forwards and I'm curious
for you what aspect of life in your 20s
was mysterious fraught with fear
perilous seem mysterious that now you
look back through the telescope of time
and and you and you have clarity that
you'd like to communicate to that former
version of yourself you know I think if
I could have said anything to myself in
my 20s if I could meet myself in my 20s
and CG I can do it now so I'm sure some
but some of the me makers will be will
be on it ASAP I think you see it's
interesting because I don't have any
regrets truly it's not to say I haven't
made mistakes along the way but I think
overall the mistakes were just part of
the tapestry that led to something good
that led to something with purpose and
all that so I don't I don't have regrets
in a traditional sense but I perhaps
wish that I had been a little bit easier
on myself and I think I would have told
myself to take a breath that this whole
thing has happened before and it's gonna
happen again and and be more accepting
of my flaws and my faults and to really
bring it back to the beginning of the
book you know you know I did a lot of
stuff that I'm not proud of when I was
in the closet and it's hard to live one
life much less to or
and I think I would have I would have
done things differently if I could have
and I would have maybe sat myself down
and said hey listen you can either be
yourself or you can see what's gonna
happen and I think most people and it
has nothing to do with sexuality it's
like be yourself that yeah that that's
the message yeah that was an agent yeah
one of my favorite asked by quotes from
the book is where you say just this to
be authentic and it's not just because
I'm a practicing cosmologists then
you'll know why it says as if that isn't
enough staying closeted it also changes
your relationship with reality that's
because every time you're inauthentic
with the universe you're disrupting your
experience of it I think that nicely
couples to what you just said so I found
the very same thing in my feel that was
you know my ambition to win the Nobel
Prize and really seeking that I became
an idol for me and once I realized that
it wasn't it wasn't so it really was
this naked Emperor so to speak I felt
deeply liberated and and almost that
kind of you know unclose ative feeling
if I can if I could even relate to it so
the last question I have is what you
become you know is obviously pundit a
thinker now an author what you do and
your and your skill set is that how much
of that was innate and how much of that
creativity imagination curiosity do you
think can be taught some some guests say
can be taught some say it's innate where
do you come down on that in that
spectrum you know it's interesting I can
answer this question more clearly having
written the book because you know one of
the things that I talked about in the
book is growing up in a family where we
debated and argued everything and every
holiday and I'm sure you have your own
version of this as well but I mean this
is the thing you know you have for Jews
at a table you have five opinions so
every holiday we had whether it was
Passover or it was Thanksgiving it was
like everybody was kind of arguing over
everything fighting over everything
there was yelling whatever and then
dessert would be served and everybody
would just kind of forget it and it was
like the next day so my dogs going crazy
right now days you heard that but we
would just sort of reset the next day so
I think some version of my tolerance for
ideas my ability to debate my ability
not to hate people because they think
different things comes from that and
then I would say the other part is that
cause of what I've done for the last
five years interviewing thinkers that
have thought about all of the stuff that
we have talked about here very very
deeply and I haven't judged whether I've
had you know Bishop Baron from the
archdiocese a Catholic priest in here or
rabbi won't be from the you know Temple
that's the sign of Temple Sinai Temple
thank you
or or skeptic like Sam Harris or
whatever it is that I've sat with these
people and treated them as individuals
who are on the experience of life I've
actually taken pieces from all of them
so people will say well Reuben how can
you be friends with Shapiro he's a
homophobe and it's like he has a
worldview that he's not he's not
imposing on me I can learn something
from him and I have and by the way I
think he's learning something from me
too yeah and I think so it's it's both I
think I've I had an upbringing that
allowed for some of this to happen and
then as an adult I applied those things
to people that had great swaths of
knowledge that I be able to that I've
been able to incorporate into a life
that is you know pretty decent well they
thank you so much this has been a really
stimulating fascinating discussion I'd
like to take a couple seconds just in
what I call the plug zone mentioned
people can find you at the Rubin report
and also your book has its own website
don't burn this book the title of the
book and you can also get it from
penguin Random House calm as well
anything else you wanna you want to
promote you mentioned locals
yeah no listen I really enjoyed this as
I said I think you you sort of take like
the high level stuff and you go a couple
layers deep which is which is really
nice and and that's actually the whole
purpose of everything that I do so it's
you know being on it on a book tour
while I'm sitting and this is my garage
yeah I thought I was going to be meeting
all these people in real life and
bouncing around and all that I think
there's a there's a particular nicety to
finding some of the interviews that are
a little different and a little quirky
ER and I thoroughly enjoyed this so yeah
reach it out well thanks very much let
me know when you do your next big
project maybe you're gonna do a Netflix
special or something so I can short the
market well I know for sure what I'm
gonna do next is walk my dog because
he's given me the signal of it
okay great all right there good luck
with the book and keep it Dutch bye-bye
[Music]
the only thing we can be sure of about
the future is it
[Music]